kopar revving it up he'll turn wide on farari
feated it back towards Point position bringing
around for dowy former Norris Trophy winner
rebound two kick saves for keer kicked out and
here's the fourth one for good measure and they
try to bog you down and force you to turn pucks
over the Caps have to be smart when they're
in that type of alignment that 131 as oetkin
Waits here needs it down low for back can't
chance Wilson denied by talet RC camper has
been extremely busy and talet the action heating
up at his doorstep two that's a difficult looking
daunting schedule the 15th and 16th the canes
and they're at the stars before they head home
oh by the way they're the best road team in the
league great stop there talbat with a robbery
save on Wilson on a rewind through neutral
Carlson sends in petti Max's pass comes all
the way through to stro stro set it back behind
the goal going to the cage here a stop attempt
stro denied by talbet and there's no rebound
because of it watch them get the puck in stro
reverses it behind the net gabov is ripped
off by Patra leading to a capital scoring
chance the Caps have been much better exiting
their Zone and then getting on the attack who
had a potential gain tying goal in the first
meeting overturned to a to a offside challenge
that was successful for Washington helped the
Caps Prevail 2-1 in that game as Carlson clears
it's on the money obey cubel with Dow right up
the gut on the backand he scores Nick [Applause]
[Music] Dow what a pass it was starts with a
good breakout skating with speed is obey cubell
a little SAU and then an even better backhand
by Nick da but look at that pass getting it away
from the defenseman Roy putting it right onto the
Stick of Dow Dow did not have time because of the
back Checker to put that puck on his forehead when
you teach at the youth hockey level this is Youth
Hockey day are you still giving instructions
on backhand shots this is deflected great save
followup chance talat with two Beauty been under
a little bit of heat nice pass by mantha by the
way just hits the Center Drive guy McMichael fala
on the go play it back to the points just kept in
there by Byfield man up for another 58 seconds
are the Kings and the white sweaters copar dowy
Slap Shot Kee he scores that was very close at the
Blue Line there the linesmen indicated it did not
cross the blue line I'm sure the cap coaching
staff will have a look at that but kempe he's
always been a terrific shooter he had a couple
of goals the other night in their loss to the the
Red Wings B here it is left side of the screen
they find him in the seam dowy lays it out for
him it goes through the legs of farari and that's
why keer was late on his reaction there it is and
might even hit that right skate boot of farari and
that foils the Cap's net allenstein protecting the
puckle along the boards Doo is close by more one
hands it to the slot then cellb beaten there keer
lost his goalie stick but still made that save to
his left being rung there's the best save I think
of the game look at keer you nailed it without
the stick at the flex off of Dow alltime meeting
number 120 between these two teams lazat back to
point position dowy hammers there stopped by keer
rebound pinballs off the post P out to deny
cev it's been a shooting machine here in the
second period they get momentum from the extra
man that one shank short side off the post k
off plays the end wall Anderson on it first for
Los Angeles then Deno Deno using the Dasher to
fiala fala nice pass to know right on in rolls
that one weakly to the front follow-up score
fiala now they got the bounce coming right back
to them and Fala made no mistake Fella's got his
ninth goal of the Season afternoon starts
right there a shot from Deno doesn't get
a whole lot of mustard on it in the left pad
of Darcy camper he kicks it out far but not
far enough and right onto the Stick of fwa
I wouldn't be surprised this is unassisted
after that shot kicks off his left P Kar feeds
unselfishly Kings working on the outside that
blast is off the crossbar from Mikey Anderson with
a rocket wellkin through Center pater ready then
for stro at the attacking line they'll drop
it to the slot area DuBois was in good shape
defensively but then he gave it up stro right on
in feeds Give It Go score stro and oetkin on the
board scoring chances they had six of them Pat
ready grips off the puck he'll get his first
Career Point as a cap and Dylan Str and Obie work
the give and go you couldn't have been any more
perfect Obie quickly gathers the puck for Pats
ready he's got his first point stro connects
again strome's got his 15th of the season to
tie it up Kings have a power play goal today
you can see that at the bottom of the screen
it came compliments of kempe a blast at 712 of
the second tied to score at the time Washington
gets possession of the draw lost it though here
and a tuck in chance fiala scores that's just
5 seconds after the draw missplay behind the
net not enough starch on the puck going behind
and that was a beautiful read by Byfield Watch
What Happens off the draw here copar actually
loses it there's that little push in front by
Carlson trying to go D to D but red by 55 watch 55
take the inside route then he puts it back and the
moving side to side and there's tiala pting his
second back to- back teams that are very good on
the draw Kopitar comes in at over 57% up the
middle they're very big and strong caps have
to remain tough loose rebound there keer made
the denial on lazza La Pierre with his Nets
off and Wilson when he comes back just about
the third cycle we've SE Pat ready there and
tight Li out off the crossbar that would have
been insurance for Los Angeles this will roll
deep into Washington territory Moore in a foot
race with farari swooping in to cover up for
Washington it's Nick Dow on the outlet to Obe
cubel slicing through Center o cuel fires he
[Applause]
scores Jimmy using Defender look at all the
men back here he's got guys everywhere there's
actually five at the top of the circle no one
attacks oy cubel he takes one step and rips
it around England and goes across his body
and it looked like T Valenstein flexes it
ahead gets the return from down in the McNugget
minute of period three Valenstein bump it out
wide slap her on the way score deflected
in front the capitals have a late lead
Doom the Kings there's a play by Dow little
transfer from melen Stein right out front
and there's the Seeing Eye Ricochet Puck off
the Blocker in front and it rolls right past
the goal tender here's the shot gets through
the legs redirected in front there Valenstein
who dished that 7 Seconds to go high SL play
copar relay to the front stick save keer two
seconds left Washington survives and sweeps
the set with another one-goal win over la